welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Marvels the 2023 Marvel teamup film with
Captain Marvel Carol Danver Monica Rambo
and M Marvel Kamala Khan and further
warning some shocking and cameos that
Marvel couldn't help but find an excuse
to throw into this mix we are back
breaking down this film shop by shop for
all the Easter eggs references and
details you missed and since back in
April of this year I teamed up to break
down the very first teaser for the
Marvels and nearly 3 years ago I teamed
up to witness Monica Rambo's MCU origin
story in one of it I proud to welcome
back to breakdown this movie with me
Jessica
Clem I'm excited to be back and excited
to talk about this movie because I loved
it so much it means a lot to me higher
further faster Jess higher further
faster I got icked by you saying it to
me but in the movie I
cried yeah yeah I shouldn't say that
anyway this Thursday November 16th new
rock stars is going to be doing a
special live show in Los Angeles at
brain dead Studios ticket info in the
description it's going be a lot of fun
and the best way to support new rock
stars is with a Flur and inspired shirt
available at nerd riot. shop thank you
to boxu for sponsoring this video more
on their tasty offerin later okay the
opening Marvel Studios fanf Fair has
been updated to include Camala Monica
and Carol all at iconic moments from
their pasts we see Cala from M Marvel
episode 6 with her iged hands Monica
when she first re-entered the West viiew
hex in W division episode 7 with her
newly acquired Powers Carol at the first
moment she went binary and Captain
Marvel but binary means something else
in this movie now Camala she first
sensed her light powers in M Marvel
episode one at Avenger con looking at
her bangle Carol walking out on the
tarmac tour of the Jets with Maria and
Captain Marvel sanhire further faster
and Monica pushing through the hex wall
in W division episode 7 yes and then on
the Marvel card and the M Carol turning
toward the camera from Captain Marvel in
the a Monica reaching her hand toward
the hex wall in W division episode 4 in
the r Carol pointed a gun to the fighter
crash site right before the explosion
gives her her powers in The V Cala lilip
padding across hard light platform and
Miss Marvel in an e Monica and her sword
shirt from W Division and in the L
Camala using her bangal now next we see
the dying red orange son of the solar
system of the planet Hala the cre home
world now in the Marvel Comics this star
is called Pama and it's contained within
the large melanic Cloud later Monica
refers to the cre Central Galaxy as the
melanic Galaxy which is a reference to
the nebula in the comics and also named
after the two irregular Dorp galaxies
that orbit the Milky Way in our universe
these were named after Ferdinand mellin
whose Navigator Antonio pigafetta
spotted these on mellon's circum
navigation Expedition from 1519 to 1522
but Pama was initially shown as a blue
son in Silver Surfer number four but
when paa is seen orbiting it in Captain
Marvel number 46 it is a yellow orange
color but really this is the crisis that
motivates Dar Ben in this movie it's a
dying Sun that needs a cosmic Miracle
Hala does get destroyed in the comics
and the cre relocate to a new planet in
the system called cre Pama luckily Carol
in this movie pulls an araras at the end
of the movie and kick starts it with a
fusion reaction at a perfect temperature
that does not fry the cre with a deadly
solar flare as I thought might happen
Dar Ben's diamond shaped warship flies
through the hexagon shaped jump Point
we've seen this Grid in the MCU before
starting with Guardians of the Galaxy
Volume 2 and it appeared again in
Captain Marvel Avengers endgame and
Guardians volume 3 it used to be known
as the UN end but this movie just calls
them jump points they were created by
the two Quantum bands darb Ben heads to
the planetoid mb48 in search of these
bands she's played in the movie by zawe
Ashton her creat advisor is Tyrone
played by Daniel Ing and yes that name
is just
Tyrone what yes now in the comics darbin
is a cre General who joins ion as joint
Emperors of the cre Empire for a Time
first appeared in Silver Surfer number
53 in 1991 but in this film she is an
accuser who carries a cosmi rod the same
Rank and the same staff carried by Ronin
and Guardians of the Galaxy and in
Captain Marvel but here Darvin seems to
be the general who won a cre Civil War
in the aftermath of Carol's annihilation
of the cre Supreme intelligence so
remember winning a war doesn't make one
a great ruler automatically and darbin
now has to make good on her promise to
the Creed to save their world darbin
puts on one of the quantum bands but
looks for the other one in the dust as
we saw in the Miss Marvel series the
other band went to Earth in India in a
cavern marked with the symbol of the 10
rings in 1942 a group of clandestines
from the nor Dimension including najma
and Aisha discovered the other band on a
severed blue arm through Aisha it passed
down kamala's family tree to her this
movie does not answer what the band's
history is with the 10 rings but one
theory is that they came to the
dimension with the 10 rings and they all
share the same ancestry remember in the
shangi film non- explained the history
of the civilization beyond talo that was
destroyed by the dweller in darkness
that realm could be connected with the
Nord Dimension and the 10 Rings all of
these come from the neighboring
Dimension or realm and one Cosmic figure
created the Gateway using the bands to
Bridge and the Rings to destroy I like
that bands to bridge rings to destroy I
mean Dart band does say that the bands
were forged as a pair forged which tells
us that some one made these so from here
we hop to Jersey City and we hear Mia's
double bubble trouble in kamala's room
we see photos of her friends Bruno and
Nakia from M Marvel and her computer is
open on the page of her YouTube channel
slothbaby Productions now we first met
Camala Khan played by Iman valani in the
2022 M Marvel series an enthusiastic
Avengers stand from Jersey City she
discovers a bangal sent to her by a
grandmother from Pakistan and uses it to
cosplay as her hero Captain Marvel at
Avenger conon the Bengal unlocks within
Kamala a power that she calls hard light
which she applies to some heroics in her
Pakistani American Community Kamala is
approached by a group called The
clandestines beings from the nor
Dimension nor meaning light led by najma
najma and kamala's great- grandmother
Aisha were banished from the nor
Dimension and it was they who found the
Bengal in 1942 on a severed blue arm in
Ruins marked with the symbol of the 10
Rings Aisha's daughter kamala's
grandmother was separated from her
family in a chaotic train station in
1947 during the partition of India and
Pakistan but in the present day during a
fight with the clandestines in Pakistan
kamala's Bengal takes her back in time
to that night and we learn it was she
who saved her own grandmother and that
the Bengal can split the fabric of space
and time and reality Miss Marvel ends
with Camala in a new suit and a moniker
from her father the name Miss Marvel
kamala's friend Bruno identifies her as
a mutant Cala there's something
different in your
jeans
like like a
mutation whatever it is it's just going
to be another label now Kamala Khan as a
Comics character debuted in 2012 as a
Carol fan and Captain Marvel Comics but
shortly after got her own 2013 spin-off
run from writer G Willow Wilson where
Kamala was identified as an inhuman but
G Willow Wilson confirmed after the M
Marvel series came out on Disney plus
that she always intended Cala to be a
mutant but back then Marvel
entertainment CEO I permut prohibited
the comics from introducing New Mutants
or X-Men or Fantastic 4 because he
didn't want to help rival movie studios
but now those rights have reverted to
Marvel Studios and obviously the MCU
characters and X-Men can appear on
screen together but when I asked tan
valani about the time travel mechanics
on her series she confirmed that her
going back in time was part of Kang's
plan do you think Kang or he remains
might have planned specifically for
Kamala to go back in time yeah okay so
the inscription on the Bengal used to be
what is destined for you will come for
you we did change it after that but I
like to use that as a way of you know
justifying how Cala goes back in time
and and why that was meant to happen so
similar to the art style of the first
episode of Miss Marvel we swoop into
kamala's notebook to see her sketches of
herself and Carol Danvers come to life
her physics equations mentions hooks law
which deals with the forces of Springs
and a note from Cala physics sucks it
does to get to know Cala you really need
to flip through her drawings Aman volani
herself famously carries around a
notebook filled with Marvel trivia and
theories and questions for Kevin feige
she showed this to Eric in your guys'
interviews cuz I screenshotted it and I
saved it in my phone she has it she
needs to keep that in like a locked case
I'm surprised he hasn't taken it away
yet we see here also on yellow strips
Kamala kind of breaks herself down
Kamala KH 16 Powers hard light likes
Comics writing fanfiction dogs niari and
smushies niari is a delicious slow
cooked meat in Pakistani Cuisine and
dislikes homework and spiders oo will
Kamala Khan find Peter Parker to be
gross she hates physics while he loves
physics they're both active YouTube
commenters I think we're looking at a
Jersey City versus queen Showdown in
secret Wars yes oh my I would I would
eat that up Camala sketches depict her
and Carol fighting a giant robot and
then a series of smaller robots could
this foreshadow those two someday
fighting Sentinels huh in Kang's Dynasty
in the Kang Dynasty comics of the late
'90s we learned that Kang's objective as
Victor timley in 1901 was direct reccon
America's history with robotics to
install a backdoor and all robotic
technology so that he could hijack all
the Sentinels in the present day ooh
twinsies I mean that'd be fun to see
them fight twinsies meanwhile on Carol
spaceship she uses scroll memory Tech
remember that she uses this to recollect
her memories that the cre had
brainwashed out of her mind and we see
flashes of events of the 2019 Captain
Marvel film so actually let's recap
Carol Denver's origin story began as an
Air Force pilot involved with the top
secret Project Pegasus back in 1989
along with her co-pilot Maria Rambo call
sign Photon they work with Dr Wendy
Lawson who we later learned as a cre
scientist who was secretly experimenting
on the teser ACT to build a light
speeded engine for SC refugees who were
hidden in Earth's orbit the cre
Commander yon rag interfered though and
Carol gets hit with a blast of cosmic
radiation released by that engine that
is powered by the Tesseract with new
powers she's brought back to the cre
home world of Hala by yon Rog who
brainwashes her to think that her name
was actually veers from the seped half
of her dog tag and she joins the cre
Star Force to hunt Scrolls but the
Scrolls capture veers and scan her
memories a process to begins to
deprogram her into realizing that the
Scrolls aren't the bad guys the cre are
so back on Earth in 1995 five Carol
meets Nick Fury and Agent Coulson and
rejoins Maria Rambo and her daughter
Monica Rambo whom she calls Lieutenant
trouble Carol defeats yon Rog and fends
off a barrage by cre militant Ronin you
remember him from Guardians of the
Galaxy and we in the movie with Carol
helping the squirrels find a new home
world and through it all we also meet
Goose the flurin an alien species that
resembles a cat but have mounts full of
tentacles that allow them to swallow
large items while Captain Marvel has a
longer history of Marvel Comics as marel
a male cre Soldier and Carol Danvers was
really his high skirted missmarvel love
interest the Cinematic version of the
characters based on Kelly sutic conics
amazing 2011 reboot of the character who
had a suit based on a pilot's flight
suit it was really conceived to have the
Gearhead mind of Tony Stark and the
Patriotic courage of Steve Rogers but
according to the book MCU the random
Marvel Studios wind toonic pitched Kevin
Vin Marvel Studios on a Captain Marvel
movie they compared Carol to a soldier
who gets knocked down and always gets
back up as a quality in line with Steve
Rogers but to conic later clarified that
instead of saying I can do this all day
when Carol Danvers gets back up she's
really just saying you Captain Marvel's
Insignia first appeared in the MCU in
the post credit scene of Avengers
Infinity war on Nick Fury's pager a
pager With An Origin revealed in the
Captain Marvel film Carol reappeared in
Avengers endgame saving everybody nearly
beating Thanos before getting walloped
by the Power Stone and then Carol
appeared in the post credit scene of
shangi when she said she was uncertain
of the 10 Rings origin and then again in
the post credit scene of the Miss Marvel
series a moment that we see in this film
but at the very end of this memory
Montage we see a new moment Carol
Landing in the structure on the planet
Hala that houses the cre Supreme
intelligence and a shot of a younger
darbin in the hall witnessing what
happened there on Carol's bookshelf is a
photo of Maria Rambo a photo of the
American southwest and an article about
astronaut Monica Rambo from the Magnolia
weekly local Louisiana Shoots for the
Stars a local louisian woman has set her
sights on the Stars after graduating
from Rice University with a degree in
Psychology and physics and astronomy
Monica Rambo oh my God I love her so
much Carol is continuing to keep tabs on
Monica's career and she identifies the
Rambo home in Louisiana as the only real
home she has left yeah she takes it at
movie she doesn't it's it's both theirs
she's holding it she's holding it down
seems like she's moving in she is moving
in don't start don't you start Carol
uses a laser pointer to direct Goose to
flurin to switch on the coffee maker and
you'll notice this is a different cat
from the one used for the 2019 Captain
Marvel that was a 12-year-old cat named
Reggie who had an orange mouth this cat
has a white mouth it's not Reggie
anymore goose is played by two cats
named Nemo and Tango and apparently Brie
Larson is highly allergic to feline
dander so anytime you see her with a cat
on her shoulder in this movie it's
probably VFX or Brie Larson is just
tripping on V that's what she gets for
stealing that home Nick Fury calls from
the saber space station we later learned
saber stands for strategic Aerospace
biophysics and exol linguistic response
the structure of the station is based on
the peak the space station of Sword and
the Marvel Comics overseen by sword
director Abigail brand in the
establishing shot of the space station
it is not labeled with the text or given
any numerical coordinates which is odd
because the trailer version of the shot
did provide this text which includes the
same c053 coordinates for Earth that we
saw in Captain Marvel yeah I wonder why
they changed it that's kind of weird
Carol calls Nick The oneeyed Man of
Mystery he calls her the prodigal child
of the Milky Way and as they talk you
can see Fury's pager on the desk in the
foreground of his office it's just a
reminder that Carol's introduction to
the MCU came in the form of a pager in
the infinity War post credit scene and
quick recap on what our man Fury's been
up to so Nick Fury met Carol Danvers in
the 2019 Captain Marvel film set back in
1995 he renamed his plan for the
protector initiative after Carol's call
sign of Avenger since Goose of flurin
held on to the tesser ACT Fury continued
Project Pegasus through the events of
the 2012 Avengers film after Avengers
endgame Nick Fury relo at to a squirrel
space station and had the srel Taos
carry out as bidding on Earth sometimes
appearing as him in the secret Invasion
series Nick Fury returns to Earth to
deal with a rebellious faction of skulls
led by gravic and ts's daughter of Gaia
who you'll remember played Uno with
young Monica in the final minutes of
Captain Marvel gravic is seeking the
Harvest in which Nick Fury had Scrolls
comb the aftermath of the endgame final
battle to recover Avenger DNA this
includes the DNA of Carol Danvers who we
didn't see bleed in that battle but
Thanos did punch her pretty hard and in
that deleted scene where they all take a
knee at Tony's cour corpse you can see
her bleeding a little bit s Invasion
ends with Gia becoming an insanely
overpowered super scroll with powers
including Carol danver's Cosmic
radiation Powers Fury goes back into
space and Marvel fans everywhere were
pretty pissed off when that series tried
to establish roie and every single one
of us scen since Captain America Civil
War in 2016 as a scroll named Raa when
Goose scrambles around at that
touchcreen to interfere I like how Fury
asks if it was goose with a bit of fear
in his voice just reminder that it was
goose who scratched his eye to give him
his iconic scars and then later in this
movie he politely Pets the Flur kid so
you know no hard feelings I love them I
love them Monica repairs the station in
a spacewalk with fellow saber astronaut
dag Abraham papula and Talia Leela fard
I'm sorry if I butchered both of your
names you're phenomenal in the movie her
hand phases through the glove of the
spacit to harness electromagnetism to
fuse the metal it's an interesting
visual choice and I think it's meant to
show that Monica can exist in open space
and shoot energy from her hands setting
her up for a big sacrifice play in the
Final Act Fury tries to connect Carol
and Monica in a conference call and the
two women do not want to talk to each
other Fury is always trying to get get
stubborn Avengers to work together maybe
he should just tell Carol that he stole
her DNA for the Harvest now we first met
Monica Rambo as played by tiona Paris in
wav Vision returning from the blip to
realize that her mother Maria died of
cancer a few years prior Monica followed
Maria's footsteps as a part of Sword
back when Monica was working as an
astronaut but now she investigates the
West VI phenomenon and gets sucked into
the hex reality that was cast by Wanda
maximoff Monica briefly befriends Wanda
but then gets cast out of the hex when
Darcy Lewis and Jimmy woo bring up Carol
Danvers from the Battle of Earth in
endgame Monica gets pretty Frosty uh she
could have taken out Thanos on her own
if he hadn't initiated a blitz I nobody
else came close her powers came from an
infinity stone too right we are not
talking about her we are talking about
Wanda Monica reenters Wanda's hex a
grueling transition through the cosmic
radiation that leaves her with
electromagnetic powers like allowing
bullets to phase through her body she
ends W Vision being approached by a
squirrel to meet Nick Fury in space and
one other detail you should know about
the Rambo family in the MCU in Doctor
Strange of the Multiverse of Madness
Lana Lynch plays Captain Marvel Maria
Rambo from the 838 universe so in at
least one other reality within the
Multiverse Maria Rambo Photon becomes
Captain Marvel not Carol daverse in this
scene Monica slowly reaches out to touch
the hexagon shaped jump Point portal and
she Whispers to herself beautiful she's
like a moth to a flame she's so drawn to
it and I love it this is also the
Instinct she followed when she reached
out to touch the radiation of the hex
wall in W division's hexagons and then
nead dasta divides the frame to show
Monica's hand and Carol's hand reaching
out to touch the same energy while
Kamala wedges in between them while
looking at her bangal this is a
beautiful way of showing that through
Kamala these two women find their way
back to each other it's really really
cool and then switch Monica takes
Carol's place on mb48 Carol takes
kamala's place in her bedroom creating
that post-credit scene of The Miz Marvel
finale and Kamala takes Monica's place
in her space suit she's screaming as
everything is spinning around her with
this point of view shot just like Sandra
Bullock and gravity and then meets Nick
Fury upside down Nick Fury hi um is this
an Avengers test I love that Camala
assumes part of the Avengers initiation
is to just be teleported out of your
bedroom into space with no warning like
that's just something they all have to
go through Carol looks around kamala's
bedroom seeing a drawing of Cala forming
the Black Widow pose with the word yes
and then drawings of the two of them
together caption besties and then Carol
and Kamala save the world make it happen
I think a valid way of seeing this movie
is as a kind of fanfiction from the
imagination of Kamala KH like it's her
dream to not only team up with Captain
Marvel but for Kamala to be the fixer of
Carol and some kind of issue in her life
like her relationship with her
Lieutenant trouble now I'm not saying
this whole movie is like hallucination
no it happened it happened I just think
it's fun to think of it as a Marvel
nerd's dream come true everything good
and bad that comes with that and that
kind of helps us forgive some of the
wackier more indulgent excesses of the
movie Carol fights Dar Ben cre soldiers
on mb48 they have the same helmets as
the soldiers and Miss minutes
orientation video in Loki episode 1
those soldiers were fighting a purple
skinned Army and we assumed those were
Titans based on the ships in the
background Carol learns that dar Ben is
going after the Scrolls on tarx tarx 4
is known in the Marvel Comics as the new
home of the Scrolls Empire following the
relocation from scrollo we saw the
destruction of scrollo in the opening of
The Secret Invasion series tarx ends up
getting destroyed by Galactus in the
comics the Scrolls have the worst look
literally imaginable definitely Carol
approaches tarax and activates some
invisibility Tech on her ship this is
the same Tech that the Scrolls used on
their space station in Captain Marvel
we've also seen on the Helicarrier in
the MCU but darbin convenes with Emperor
dro the leader of the srels that was
mentioned by Taos in episode two secret
Invasion you're telling me there's a
million Scrolls walking amongst us right
now have you lost your reptilian ass
mind I sent out the call and every
scroll that isn't in Emperor Georgia's
Colony they answered in the Marvel
Comics The Scroll droi Fu IDU is the
high priest scientist who invent super
scroll technology but here he is the
leader of the Scrolls a Scottish
character actor Gary Lewis they
discussed a long history of squirrel
persecution by the cre Empire and at
first it seems like Dar is totally
sympathetic like she says when her
predecessor was destroyed Heretics
filled the void and their Planet
collapsed as their son began to die but
remember since this was a civil war
successors to the cre Supreme
intelligence were only Heretics from
darb Ben's point of view she just ousted
whoever took over afterward and then
branded them as Heretics in this chamber
there's some interesting scroll artwork
carved into the walls with multiple
layers like it's showing the scroll
transformation process in a snapshot it
looks vaguely similar to the opening
animation of the secret Invasion title
sequence but Dar Ben says she'll help
with the location saying she would hate
for the Scrolls to suffocate when she
strips the atmosphere that's right she's
taking their air it's mine mine I want
it God damn it yeah doesn't it feel like
this is kind of similar to The Plot In
Space Balls where president screw and
Dark Helmet try to use the mega made to
vacuum up the air from Jia I mean it's
silly but it's it's fun NE dasta is a
Space Balls fan uh and I think that's
insane to think about for this carol
uses her powers and swaps with Kamala
and Cala Witnesses how a flurin
works
oh my God yeah remember she's not just
reacting to the cat she's reacting to
teleporting to a random squirrel hallway
and then seeing a cat eat someone Kamala
makes a shield and then swaps again this
time with Monica and Cala brings Goose
to their living room while Cricket is
playing on the TV Goose coughs up to cre
and then I love this the flurin
immediately hisses at them Carol swaps
with Kamala and joins the whole con
family in fighting the two cre the music
here is ratatata by Skrillex Miss Elliot
and Mr oo I probably pronounced that
wrong again and I'm so sorry the song is
still really good this sequence doesn't
always show it but remember every time
there's a swap one of the three is back
with Fury in the space elevator trying
to explain what's going on Kamala traps
some cre from tarx and a bubble from her
hard light so all of them get swapped to
the space elevator with Nick Fury
whenever Kamala teleports somewhere
confusing just seeing Nick Fury is
enough to make her feel like she's at
home back in the con house Goose helps
by using his tentacles to move the chair
out from under Monica so she Dodges the
attack but then he swallows the chair
goose is particularly curv esque in this
movie and we later learned it's because
the flurin is
pregnant yeah entanglement is a big
component of what makes the Marvels fun
and you can keep that fun going by
entangling snacking and surprise with
bxu bxu is a premium Japanese snack box
that works with family businesses all
over Japan to deliver a new theme of
authentic Japanese snacks every month
and honestly it makes a great gift fun
snacks that you usually have to travel
to try people love it and Beyond the
snacks each boxu comes with a booklet
that teaches you all about the theme and
where the snacks come from so that you
can have a deeper appreciation for what
it is you're munching on the first box
of any box you subscription is the
seasons of Japan after that you receive
a new theme every month with curated
seasonal snacks one of my favorite
things for these is a white strawberry
it's so sweet and the strawberries
infused with white chocolate to just
make like oh my God it's Heaven it's a
bite of heaven I'm telling you but they
also have these Smoky radish chips which
compared with the the sweet white
chocolate strawberry this just makes for
a nice Smoky something something
oh yeah o so good so good both I and the
new Rockstar's office have been
receiving these boxes for ages we love
them so if you want to try boxu and
support the channel click the link in
the description and use code rockstars
to get $15 off your order so Monica
absorbs energy from the spear so she's
able to throw this cre but then she
flies behind him to phase through him
and then punches him in the face and in
doing so swaps back with Kamala now at
one point Nick Fury just kills this cre
while he's just sitting in a seated
position like we read in the amazing
book MC reing the Marvel Studios that
Samu L Jackson apparently hates running
in these movies so I love that they
found a way to give him a kill without
even having to stand up what he hates it
he's like don't make me run he shows up
to Star Wars he's like give me a purple
saber he goes to Marvel he's like I'm
not running now when Cala and her family
sweep up the mess there is a newspaper
in the rubble that reads how the new
government's Towers could affect you H
now this could be referring to
government like Telecom Towers maybe a
kind of conspiracy tabloid headline but
I actually wonder if it could could be
referring to the government takeover of
Avengers Tower which might be one of
many towers that the government is
taking through imminent domain in recent
years that would just lend Credence to
the speculation that CIA director Val is
the one who has overtaken Avengers Tower
Fury and Monica arrive and Monica pulls
up kamala's file on a tablet Kamala
asked if this is all top secret
information then why is it on a clear
case later when she holds up the tablet
to cover her face for a secret side chat
with Monica Camala forgets it's clear
and her brother can actually see her
Muna worries that the government is
surveilling them recalling the jerk
agent dver and Miss Marvel who use the
dodc investigation as an excuse to do
some racial profiling on Muslims in
Jersey City this is a real thing that
Muslim communities in America have to
face all the time Fury response
surveillance is a strong word because
for him he learned a hard lesson about
government overreach with project
insight and Captain America the Winter
Soldier Monica explains you can absorb
light I can see it and Camala who's Cala
can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of yeah the
additionally weird element to kamala's
power set probably comes from her mutant
status it's not just the electromagnetic
manipulation that she can do Kamala can
use light as an extension of her body
and surfaces to bounce off of Kamala
swaps with Carol and Carol and Monica
see each other again for the first time
in years it is so good to see you
lieutenant trouble you too and it's
Captain Rambo now yeah Carol is calling
Monica by her childhood nickname and
Monica is like that's not my name but I
like how this sets up Carol to miss
having a little sister figure and Cala
just fits that void perfectly in this
movie Carol asks when did you get powers
I walked through a radiation shielding
barar of a witch heex and now I can
manipulate and see all wavelengths of
the electromagnetic spectrum witch heex
somewhere Wanda is like keep my name out
youring mouth she is she straight up is
but Nick Fury totally makes fun of the
fact that Monica got her powers from a
witch heck shouting at Monica black girl
magic to get her to fly up and save Cala
after UNC Carol tried to kill her I
grabbed John in the theater I said what
did you just say cuz I wasn't sure I
heard it correctly Kamala in the scene
wears a shirt with two Captain Marvel
comic books these are not real Captain
Marvel Comics they were designed in the
style of Captain Marvel Comics though
and I remember when we had to research
this hard and we could not find it cuz
it didn't exist find don't exist as Cala
Falls the camera never shows Midtown
Manhattan just the financial district in
Jersey City so we never get a clear shot
of where Avengers Tower would be it's
located near Grand Central Station to
the site of the real world metti
building so Monica and Kamala swap with
Carol and Fury's like oh good it's Carol
and then they get stuck with darb Ben on
tarx but Carol flies in at the last
second to save them now I know Carol can
move fast Jess but I do not understand
how she got to this precise point across
the Galaxy so quickly like it seems like
there was a plot hole in the way that
the sequence came together or maybe a
deleted scene but the VFX artist you can
tell just painted in Carol in the
distance behind Camala and Monica
gradually approaching to try to justify
it I think and then she just appears out
of nowhere to block Darin's blast I
think the scene just isn't edited in a
way to build tension around Carol
approaching in the background there like
if you were disoriented by this First
Act it's okay it was just a bit messy
it's still very fun just a bit messy
there's also a crazy moment I don't know
if you heard this just when Carol
appears and in the scoring or the sound
mix there is like a vocal scream and I
thought that was coming from our theater
same but yeah it's so weird I think it's
something they added to the mix to
underline Darin's rage at Carol for
being the annihilator who ended the cway
of life but it's a really weird Choice
darbin rips open a portal above tarac
sucking the air out and destroying the
colony Cala tries to save as many
Scrolls as she can but they have to
leave several behind you can actually
see innocent lives behind in the valley
to suffocate switch oh my gosh I um just
um swapped with John we're cosmically
entangled he's in San Francisco now so
I'm here oh my God he's in San Francisco
you're in La honestly no better place
for John to be away from his yeah don't
Le Stu in your car John anyway uh shall
we continue with this breakdown yes
please let's do it so the bifrost hits
Carol's ship and Valkyrie appears now
the last we saw Valkyrie was in Thor 11
Thunder she was training Heim doll son
Axel remember his cool VFX face so axel
might be steering the Bost currently
Valkyrie says I've been in some
unintentional teams myself referring to
the revengers from Thor Ragnarok but
also the lineup that these two
characters shared in endgame Valkyrie
takes these Scrolls presumably back with
her to new Asgard which is especially
interesting after the recent
Proclamation by the US president in the
secret Invasion finale presenting to
Congress for immediate emergency
authorization a bill that designates all
offworld born species enemy
combatants we know who you
are we know how to find
you and we will kill every last one of
you yikes Valkyrie is bringing these
squirrels to a planet with a very
hostile superpower hunting them down but
ritzen declared war on all
extraterrestrials including the
asgardians as much as the srel so
perhaps new Asgard might be coming a
kind of sanctuary state or maybe
Valkyrie has moved everyone in new
Asgard somewhere else like thanos's
retirement Planet the garden uh let's
hope let's pray darb Ben takes us back
to the incident where Carol destroyed
the cre supr intelligence in the 2019
Captain Marvel film we never saw the
Supreme intelligence's True Form it took
on a new appearance depending on whoever
was meeting with it but now we see its
true appearance and it's a massive green
face with dangling circuitry this is how
the cre Supreme intelligence looks like
in the comics it's a vast cybernetic
computer system with Acres of circuits
connecting the disembodied brains of the
greatest leaders and thinkers in cre
history it was created to help the cre
race Outlast the end of its evolutionary
path all of the cre Society runs from
the Supreme intelligence yeah so like
thousands of years of cre aristotles cre
Benjamin Franklin's cre Gandhi they were
all wiped out this wasn't the equivalent
of like a Kevin robot that Carol could
have unplugged it was cryogenically
preserved like Saints of this Society
Saints who admittedly algorithmically
decided to Gaslight Carol and
exterminate the squirrels but still
Carol left the cre with no alternative
government no there was a civil war
afterwards but it's interesting just to
think about when Carol did this because
darban says quote for 30 years I've been
fighting alongside you the Marvels takes
place in 2025 because the M Marvel
finale took place in Spring 2025 so 30
years before that would be 1995 the year
of the first Captain Marvel film so that
was the year Carol parted ways of the
cre so like she left Yan Rag and went
right back to aalla to wreck the Supreme
intelligence and that would mean that
the cre had been in this state of unrest
for the entire time that we've known
them in the MCU including the first
Guardians of the Galaxy movie with Ronin
could Ronin be that heretic that darb
Ben alludes to it's just all this is
wild no wonder they're they're
allowed to be at this point and now I
kind of fight for the crew
maybe we should edit that out I don't
know if people I want people to know
that I fight for the cre regardless
Kamala asked Carol if the name Miss
Marvel is copyright infringement the
name Captain Marvel came from the
copyright dispute between Marvel and the
owners of the rights of the original
Captain Marvel AKA Shazam which is why
Stan Lee in 1967 got around it by naming
the character
Marvel so cartoony Kamala continues to
brainstorm on the moniker for Monica
trying Professor Marvel Professor Marvel
was the fortune teller character in The
Wizard of Oz yes Oz Cala tells them that
her bangal once travel Tred her through
time and space and Carol says their
proper name is quantum bands Carol says
she thought Quantum bands were a myth a
cre Legend devices that were used to
create every jump point in the universe
yeah so Quantum bands are from Marvel
Comics originating in fantastic Board
number 164 and appearing throughout the
quazar comics and the annihilation
Conquest story line they are bands that
draw energy from the quantum Zone that's
the realm from which all actual energy
in the Marvel Universe deres and they
were actually created by Eon a cosmic
entity who oversees time we actually saw
this mess head as one of the statues in
eternity's chamber in thor1 Thunder so
the bands in the comics were given to
Kronos who is the father to Alas and
alas was the father to Thanos and AOS so
in the comics it was these bands that
allowed allars and suisan to sire those
two over the years the bands have been
worn by characters like quazar anas f
Lael who we just saw in Guardians volume
3 Nova and now Wendel Von AKA blue
Marvel but this confirmation is just
such a huge deal the quantum Zone from
the comics could be in the MCU the
quantum Realm or maybe the nor Dimension
these bands may be the link between
everything Marvel Cosmic Thanos the tin
Rings the quantum realm and Kamala Khan
I kind of feel like that gold marking
that Carol dusted off on mb48 might have
been connected to quazar Oh I like that
Monica mention Dar space Hammer thingy
which Carol says is called the Universal
Weapon Cala says she was going to call
it the cosmet rod cosmet rod has been
the name used for this Warhammer in the
MCU since it was wielded by Ronin and
Guardians of the Galaxy but in Marvel
Comics its name is the Universal Weapon
carried by cre accusers Carol gives them
all scroll devices to actively scrub
through their memory yeah and we see a
lot of fun Disney plus callbacks here
because there's one frame of a black and
white shot of Monica in 60s attire this
we know is from W Vision episode 2 when
she first met W maxoff this is the scene
where we heard around the world quote
the devil's in the details Bev and the
Mesto train left the station thanks a
lot for that quote sha man you really
make gave me a fun weekend but then we
see a quick shot of Monica pushing
through the hex wall and then kamala's
memories from Miss Marvel including when
she first found the bangal in the attic
and then Carol getting in the cockpit of
the Rambo plane with young Monica and
then Monica from W Vision episode 3 when
she was in the 70s attire then Camala
from Miss Marvel episode 4 when she was
in Pakistan and vers dawned that blue
mask yes and a flashback shows Maria
Rambo telling Carol that the cancer is
back this was during the blip because
Maria died while Monica was dusted away
Maria wants Carol to take care of goose
at least until you know Monica comes
back Maria always had hope that the dust
victims would return there's a quick
shot of Monica dusting they used that
from W Vision episode 4 where her potes
came back together but they played it in
reverse here and sped it up we also see
Monica briefly in the moment she jumped
in front of the bullets to save Billy
and Tommy in W division episode 9 all
three of their memories are mixed we got
monac realizing her mother died after
she returned from the blip Kamala
crouching over the body of her
great-grandmother Aisha after njma had
stabbed her in Miss Marvel episode 5
Carol watching Dr Wendy lost and die and
Captain Marvel so after these memories
they pull up a star map now these
planets are all coded the way m418 was
there's G H 528 there's PF 919 there's
VG 429 and according to the design team
perception who put all these in there
these are all the initials in the
birthdays of the artists who worked on
this so VG 429 is Veronica Gail born
April 29th that's why all the
three-digit codes the latter two never
go above 31 meanwhile manibo recognizes
that goose is looking kind of pudgy and
that flurin spins way too long looking
itself why well cat owners know that
when cats are about to go into labor
they lick their abdomen and genital
region persistently ooh I didn't know
that and I own three cats that scene was
too long Kamala continues brainstorming
names for Monica pitching Spectrum
vision and Carol says Vision then
apologizes because there's already an
Avenger with that name a dead one again
Wanda wherever she is keep his name out
your mother
mouth the BC boys Intergalactic plays as
the three of them learn to sink through
switches I know it was all over the
trailers but it's the perfect song for
three people working together and trying
to synchronize with their perfect time I
mean on one rhymed word well now don't
you tell me to
so we see like a major case of Ora
Borealis that's you know the northern
lights and these are caused by charged
electrons and protons colliding with
gases in Earth's upper atmosphere and
Earth's magnetic field steers the charge
particles toward the poles and since the
unn uses Cosmic radiation that would
result in a higher quantity of
atmospheric particles charging than
normal and it kind of gives us a cool
visual ticking clock for the increasing
level of danger that Earth finds itself
in and I love this dag tells Yousef that
he's 306 years old and when he and Talia
discovered the Floren egg he says sweet
sarim now selheim is one of the nine
Realms in the Asgardian star map and
it's considered the dark world it's home
to the dark elves so it's kind of like
him saying holy hell and I suppose that
makes tag an Asgardian a recruit from
the new Asgard colony which would
explain his awesome hair and beard yes
he's beautiful Monica now wears the 9-in
nails t-shirt that Carol stole in the
Captain Marvel film they land on the
planet alad planet that comes from
Captain Marvel number n in 2014 where
everyone speaks in rhyme and women
choose men to be their mates until their
practice was abolished by Prince Yan
this film heightens that to be an all
musical planet and I I I eat this up I
ate this up we learned that Carol
previously helped Yan with a legal issue
by marrying him to overcome a power
struggle in a matriarchal society it
sounds like Carol helped dismantle the
matriarchy Carol mine it's mine it's
mine there's a really fun design detail
that was telling us about while we were
working on this in the palace its roof
is in the shape of organ pipes and if
you look around everything has this fun
curved texture to it a lot of the
platforms are in the shape of music
notes treble clefts bass clefts one of
those like announcers who was like oh
they're coming like his hair pieces were
definitely trouble cffs as a musical
theater nerd I just I love this goofy
Planet you know like in every shot in
this part of the movie look at Aman
valani she is just fully rocking out but
rumor has it there was more to the
section of the movie that was edited out
of the film and I wonder if it was some
character beats to make these three out
of sync Heroes have to learn how to like
harmonize or sync their choreography
like something musical related so they
can learn to start working together
because otherwise just kind of going to
a musical Planet just seems random very
fun but I'll admit random actually
speaking of musical theater stuff the
Royal atache with the amazing voice is
Daniel Montero who has played Simba and
various other roles in the UK company of
The Lion King good for him Prince Yan
gives the three of them new battle
outfits and a legion of soldiers Camala
pitches another moniker Pulsar which is
another codeen name used by Monica Rambo
in the comics Monica tears off the extra
sashes but Kamala keeps her costume as
it is then later Yan tells Kamala to use
her scarf as a weapon so have Monica
kept those sashes in place maybe they
would have helped her out yeah cool
outfits darb Ben forces arrive the
battle begins I love how Monica just
phases through Prince Yan Monica and
Carol both try to blast darbin first at
the same time using their powers at the
same time so they switch and they both
misfire it's kind of like the three
Peter Parker initially failing to swing
together in harmony they're just out of
step and then Carol takes the wheel and
tries to push things higher further
faster but because she's trying to do it
alone it doesn't work mhm Nia dasta said
she based a lot of the action visuals on
Final Fantasy 7 Advent Children which
she used in her pitch to direct this
movie She cited the fight scenes in the
ending sequence where a character is
thrown into the sky because things
aren't going well Kamala makes the call
to retreat and then they land on this
grassland planet and there's this odd
wide shot of the ship landing and the
three of them deboarding arguing and I'm
pretty sure the three of them are vfxs
in this shot because when we cut to them
in closeup notice how the three actors
are clearly on a green screen set or the
volume and then that they're only shown
in single shots as they have this like
dramatic moment talking to each other
and healing I just think this might be a
bit rushed and they put this in the
movie just to make sure that they hit
this crucial moment where they're
healing where they're resetting before
the final battle just so Carol could
like confess her guilt of her Hala but I
because just the visual looks so like
neutral and odd I I think there might
have been a different version of this
scene in the storyboard or in the
previous interesting the flerkens hatch
my favorite scene Talia thinks they're
doomed and dag says in the end none of
us choose how we transfer from this life
to the next this is truly some Asgardian
platitude that's what makes Valhalla so
sacred to them the warrior chooses to
rush into their fate head on and since
the flerkens mounts contain these pocket
realities to house whatever they swallow
they use the Flur and kits to swallow
all the sa Cadets so that they can cram
into these Evac pods and it is set to
memory from adre Lloyd Weber's cats and
it's sung here by Barbara strand oh yeah
it's not the original cast recording
it's Barbara's cover and it's better for
I mean the original cast recording is
great but but it's Barbara and you know
everyone makes fun of cats because that
stupid movie in 2019 but it's supposed
to be campy and look you can have your
opinions about the sequence and you know
marvel loves to try to have animal save
the day even in stories that are not
about nature versus industry and a lot
of people can't get on board with it I
love it though and I think what I love
most about it is the fact that the saber
cadetes are terrified the PA
announcement is telling everyone to stop
running and let the Flur and swallow
them and they can't they can't do it
it's just so funny to me I love that
this movie is like about three very
strong very very strong women but that
feminine push is still coming through
even when it's like Cats the musical
these kittens but they're monstrous and
strong just like these women beautiful
strong I I love that scene I ate it up
okay back on track Fury's pod plunges to
Earth past the Statue of Liberty which
is copper colored this connects the
Marvels to the continuity of Spider-Man
no way home which featured New Yorkers
restoring the Statue of Liberty from its
green oxidized color to its original
copper with Lady Liberty holding C
Shield Miss Marvel episode 6 originally
showed the Statue of Liberty with its
real world green color but since then
Disney plus updated the episode so that
statue appears copper so the rift that
darbin opens to scyon Earth's sun is too
unstable and it causes bolts of purple
light to crack through space and yeah
this does look quite a bit like the
reality cracks in Spider-Man no way home
from Doctor Strange's spell and it is
the same general concept that was one
Rift opening to Sony's Universe of
Marvel characters this Rift opens to the
fox Universe of Marvel characters insane
darbin regains her hammer and presses it
to kamala's head its purple glow looks
like the way Thanos pressed the Power
Stone to Thor's Temple to threat Loki
and infinity War Darin gains the second
quantum band The Rift blows open and
darbin disintegrates and if you look
closely as the purple's energy surges
through the rift you can see in the
distance briefly a black hole ooh we
really didn't get an accurate cinematic
depiction of a black hole until
Christopher Nolan's Interstellar in 2014
it's because Kip Thorne like Adis like
hey this is what it would look like and
Christopher Nolan's like I will spend
several years of my life conceiving this
and putting it on screen basically this
is what it looks like if you look in the
background there it's kind of like a
ring of light surrounding a dark disc
with another band of light cutting
across it the Event Horizon we saw black
holes looking like this in Loki season 1
episode 6 as we transferred from one
Universe into the other in ly season 2
has referenced going into black holes as
a cause of spaghettification and a book
on black holes was among the collection
of OB AKA ad Doug so here that black
hole flashes into a new universe on this
other side of this Rift and notice how
there's a red orange colored nebula
surrounding another planet perhaps an
alternate Earth the mid credit scene
suggests that this is is the earth of an
X-Men Universe in that video I did
breaking it down I argue that it could
be a continued timeline following the
happy ending epilogue of X-Men Days of
Future Past this red orange Cloud that's
surrounding Earth has me a bit concerned
though could be the Phoenix Force maybe
though the redness is a symptom of this
Earth undergoing an incursion ooh I like
that KIRO and Kamala blast Monica with
the same energy that tore this hole the
two bands plus Carol Cala Whispers bismo
we heard this throughout Miss Marvel
it's Arabic for in the name of God the
merciful and compassionate Monica
transforms her body glows and her eyes
shine silver Carol says your mom would
be proud and Monica responds higher
further faster it's not spoken but
Monica becomes Photon In This Moment
Photon was her mother's call sign and
it's the only rightful moniker for her
to use and do you think by saying bismal
like uh Kamala was like blessing this
moment like there was a higher power of
gods who was elevating Monica to the St
status yeah I that's how we'll think
about it so Monica pulls the hexagonal
tiles back into place sealing herself on
the other side of it now whereas before
before it was Monica who zipped up to
try to catch Camala and she just kind of
flew through Camala now it's Carol
trying to save Monica and simply flying
through that empty space so the cons
help Carol move into the Rambo house in
Louisiana Carol carries two huge boxes
that she just kind of like smushes
together one is marked Goose snacks and
the other is Carol snacks Carol is
apparently a bit of a snacker and I
assume that Carol did not buy those
snacks from locally owned stores because
she prefers snacks with no seasoning on
them M you said M this
this is my house why is she moving into
it I want that to be the only takeaway
from this movie is why would she take
their house um miva finds the golden
tray from alad depicting Carol and
Prince Yan is Prince Yan dead is yeah
what happened to Prince Yan in this
movie we don't well just cuz the water's
gone doesn't mean they're all dead did
they take all their water some of their
water if they had
96.6% it's probably majority gone but
taking out all the water from a planet
wouldn't kill it right
deel God they got to come back to it
they're going to come back to it and
we'll see him he'll be fine singing he's
bilingual Carol sits in the cockpit of
the Rambo plane with Camala Carol says
she's just looking out for it until
Monica gets back echoing Maria's hope
that Monica would return from the blip
someday so I broke down both the final
scene and mid credit scene in our other
video but just to recap Cala recruits
Kate Bishop who's introduced in the
Hawkeye series to join a Young Avengers
lineup saying that she put out feelers
to Cassie Lang and yes sine payo much to
Nick Fury's first recruiting of Tony
Stark to join the Avenger initiative in
the Iron Man post credit scene and then
the mid- credit scene has Monica waking
up in the basement medical Bay of the X
mansion with Maria Rambo from this other
Universe going by the moniker binary who
never had a daughter and Kelsey gramar
returns as Hank McCoy beasts last scene
X in Days of Future Past and X in The
Last Stand but he is a VFX reconception
of the character they use like motion
capture and like they use a character
model similar to what they use for Mark
ruffle over Hulk like I think he just
has the same face with different facial
hair and glasses McCoy mentions Charles
one in an update Charles Xavier exists
somewhere in this mansion and we hear
the X-Men movie themes from X to X-Men
United and Days of Future
Past what a film what a it it was so
crazy to see this movie all play out
seeing all the flerkin seeing all of it
Go and being like I love these three
women more than anything more than life
itself but here's Kelsey gramar KY GES
and I was like this is crazy and this is
the second time we're going to see
Xavier in the MCU that is alive uhuh
this one's alive I hope somehow someone
tells him that he died in another
reality I think he knows I think he
knows he felt it Jessica thank you so
much for coming back to break down this
movie with me let's do this again soon
of course anytime anywhere further
faster further faster follow Jessica at
Lulu Clemens follow me at EOS subscribe
to all three channels on the new
rockstars Network hey grab one of these
FLIR and shirts from nerd rot. shop and
come hang out with us if you live in the
LA area we got a live show Thursday
November 16th at brain dead Studios
we'll see you next time bye everybody
bye
[Music]